thanks for having me are you kidding me
oh my god this is so fun being here i
love it
i
i have known you now what is it like 25
years yes i'm so bad with math but it's
it's so long so long drew is it 25 years
yeah at least yeah yeah it might be
longer yeah that's wild um this book
made me feel like i was meeting you for
the first time oh thank you drew it
really did
it's so incredible thank you and
the book opens and you're talking about
your childhood and everything is
peaceful and normal and you're in a big
family a mom a dad
two sisters yes and then um in 1969 your
family was coming home from a party um
it's a long drive home
people are tired there's debates whether
to take the car ride or not
and it
matriculates into a car accident
and that crash killed your mom
and your baby sister and cousin and you
are in the car mm-hmm
how
was it writing about this
yeah
and i was going to say so in that
accident too my dad did survive he was
very badly injured his legs were badly
injured and my um so yeah so my baby
sister was killed but my older sister
mary survived too so there were three
deaths three three survivors
my life changed in a split second the
rug was pulled from under me life as i
knew it changed in one second
and it was it was
it was
you know uh
it was
it was really hard you know so
writing that chapter once i was done
with that chapter i was like okay take a
deep breath now we can get on with the
story but i kind of i couldn't i could
not not include it because it
losing my mom at an early age had a
profound effect on my life and um and
then my dad went on to
you know he he was devastated of course
too and then he went on to raise two
girls he tried his hardest i really
admired him and you know that was not so
easy he had braces on his legs from the
accident had to learn to walk again
and um he really gave it gave it his all
you know it was like skiing down
you know the black diamond uh
ski slope with no poles not the easiest
you know yes yeah yeah absolutely you're
one of the
most emboldened brave fearless
people and so it's so humanizing because
i would imagine and maybe i'm assuming
wrong but
even me who's bold like watches you to
marry katherine gallagher and sally
o'malley and all your characters and
thank god the spine on that woman
looks so funny
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you i mean there's a picture of
you i think it's the first time you're
doing marry katherine gallagher and you
are mid-air
sandler's in the frame oh my god and you
are
i don't i'm like oh she's gonna land
there's no strings you are in mid-flight
and that kind of freedom yeah how do you
have that kind of freedom and then also
you know
intimacy and and struggle like yeah how
does that work well i think it gave me
the performance that character is just
kind of an exaggerated
version of how i felt when i was little
i kind of anxious and accident prone and
like passionate and i just amplified it
by like a thousand and i would get very
nervous performing live on snl me molly
shannon but i would use the nervous
energy in the performance like when they
jenna
rosatano was counting me down
you know before i went on to do the
first marry catherine she's like okay
we're ready and five four three two
i my heart is pounding you know it's
like an adrenaline rush it's i'm
definitely scared but i just like go
through it and um i think the physical
release felt really good and um
it just i just like get in the moment
like in the zone you really did kill it
on snl and
you made these famous characters that we
still quote every day of our lives i
mean it's really crazy
thank you so much
and i think that is a fun way in which
we get to like love something and the
person i mean i do the you know sally
o'malley i'm actually going to be 50 not
so far away you know and everything is
mary katherine gallagher
[Music]